do you think your resume is good enough
to impress the hiring manager
will it help you in bagging your dream
job
now that might be quite a task not to
worry we have you covered with the best
resume tips
hey everyone welcome to this live
session on resume building and cover
letter
in this session we will guide you on how
to build your resume from scratch
we will acquaint you with the do's and
don'ts to keep in mind while crafting
your resume
additionally we will also help you
understand the importance of a cover
letter
and how to go about it let's wait for a
bit as people join in
before we proceed make sure to hit the
subscribe button and the bell icon to
never miss an update from simplylearn
let's get started and understand what
exactly a resume is
and the importance of it in a
professional's life
resumes are the first point of contact
with recruiters
a resume is a document that highlights
your career goals educational
qualifications
technical and non-technical skills
achievements co-curricular activities
and interest areas only if your resume
is impressive will you make it to the
interview rounds
resumes speak volumes about you to the
hiring panel
hence it is of utmost importance that
you package your resume well
to get shortlisted by hr's remember you
barely have six to seven
seconds to create a positive impression
with your resume
resumes are crucial for both freshers
and experienced professionals
employers use resumes throughout a
hiring process to understand
more about the applicants and to
evaluate if they might be a good fit or
not
your resume should be easy to read and
should briefly state your
accomplishments and skills
there are several points to keep in mind
while building a resume
and here we will give you the 10 most
important tips for the same
maybe you have finished writing your
resume or you're just starting
these tips will surely help you either
way
our first tip to you is to pick the
right type of resume
there are different types of resumes
like a chronological resume
this type of resume focuses primarily on
your work history
then we have a functional resume that is
designed to focus on your relevant
skills
rather than your work history
combination resume as the name suggests
mixes elements of the chronological and
functional resume formats
on the other hand a targeted resume is
one that specifically addresses the
needs of
each company you apply to such a resume
can be made
as either a functional chronological
resume or a combination resume
however the area of focus here is to
target the detailing to the job role you
are applying for
in most cases the right type of resume
depends on your work experience
most candidates who are freshers use the
functional resume format
instead of the more commonly used
chronological resume
so first and foremost you need to pick
the right type of resume before filling
in the resume details
in this live session we will be focusing
on how to build a resume for freshers
if you are refresher you can go with the
functional resume
shown alongside is the resume we are
going to build
this resume for freshers is going to be
focusing on your skills
achievements and educational details we
will have a look at how we build this
resume from scratch in the next couple
of minutes
after having decided the format and type
of resume you are going to be focusing
on
our next tip to you is to have a
blueprint of it
it is wise to pre-plan and organize the
resume content
this way you will better understand what
needs to be in the resume and what can
be excluded
just like how blueprints help you in
your projects so do they for your resume
a blueprint allows you to envisage the
bigger picture
this way you can ensure you are adding
every point in your resume
having a blueprint guides you throughout
the process of resuming building
it enables you to visualize the overall
resume
a few points to keep in mind while
formulating a blueprint of a freshers
resume
is to clearly highlight your skills and
achievements
the next tip is to include only the
sections that you need
for instance if you're following a
resume template
you can think and remove any section
that you don't require
freshers needn't include a work history
section
and instead fill it with project details
skills and academic achievements
having a blueprint will help you decide
what content has to go on the resume and
what can be omitted
once the blueprint is ready our third
tip is to start building your resume
with a good headline
a resume title or headline is a catchy
statement that speaks volumes of you and
highlights your attributes
it is imperative that you have an
impressive short and powerful headline
resume headlines give an overview of
your background to the recruiters
hence craft a good two to three liner
summary about your career goals and
qualifications
you could also add some relevant
keywords from the job description to
capture the recruiter's attention
this will help you stand out from the
rest of the candidates
a resume headline is a brief statement
that summarizes the value you bring to
the job
most recruiters do not have time to read
your entire resume
so an impressive headline can get you
noticed faster
craft your headline well enough to make
the recruiter want to read your resume
further
remember you just have a few seconds to
impress the recruiter with your catchy
headline
as a fresher your resume headline should
focus on your attributes that can
contribute to the job you are applying
for
and the company as shown alongside your
resume headline is located right at the
top of your resume
below your name this makes it the first
thing to be noticed
here for example we are giving the
headline as an engineer seeking
challenges in data analytics
to help companies with data-driven
decisions
interested in solving real life problems
using cutting-edge technologies
this clearly displays the qualification
of the candidate along with her career
interest
you could tailor the headline to meet
your interest and you could also add a
few keywords from the jd
the next tip to keep in mind before
proceeding to the body of your resume is
to make sure to add your contact
information
this might be an obvious step however
missing this will be a huge loss
your contact information will be used by
recruiters to contact you
here you can incorporate information
like your name phone number and email id
you can also add your address resumes
can also have your professional profiles
for better credibility
you could add your linkedin profile link
and github link
now with many interviews happening
online you can also mention your skype
id
make sure that every detail you give is
right and it must look professional
shown alongside we have given details
like email id
phone number place of residence linkedin
profile link and github profile links
since the name is already on the resume
it needn't be added again
make sure to always add your full name
on your resume and it is also great if
you could have a professional image of
yourself on the top most corner of your
resume
moving to contact details having your
address generally helps if you're
looking for a job within a particular
distance from your home
you could also elaborate on the address
the next tip to keep in mind is to have
a professional looking email address on
your resume
it is always advice that you have your
personal phone number on the resume to
keep the job search confidential
as shown alongside always place your
contact information on top
so that it can be easily noticed by the
recruiters
and make sure that you align them well
moving on to filling in the body of your
resume our next tip is to highlight your
educational details
like mentioned previously this resume
that we are building is for freshers
hence the first part of our resume can
be the educational qualifications
education is one of the main areas
employers look for on your resume
it is another way for an employer to
comprehend if you are the right fit
for the role if your education aligns
with the posted job role it can be a
huge advantage
so how to go about feeding your
education and details and what are the
details you need to have
let's look at that now this section of
educational qualification should have
the name of your most recent degree
name of your university and location if
possible
following which you must mention the
dates attended and your graduation date
or expected graduation date if you're
still studying
the next part should be your scores in
cgpa or percentage
better the scores the better your resume
looks
you could also add any academic honors
or relevant coursework or study abroad
programs
if you have two degrees always start
with your highest degree first
as shown alongside you can have the name
of the degree
below which you can have the university
name start
and end date of the course and finally
the cgpa
similarly we have another section of the
school details below the college details
it is good to show your school details
as well you can follow the same drill
for this too
if you wish you can have another section
below this for additional educational
details
and mention the certifications you
possess and any presented papers
we have shown that in a separate section
of this resume we shall look at it in
our further slides
the next section is one of the most
important areas of a resume
this is your skill section remember to
highlight your skills in a way that
recruiters find them relevant to the job
role you are applying for
you could choose a set of hard skills
and soft skills that you possess
and additionally you could sprinkle a
few skills that are mentioned in the job
description
skills can be your natural talents or
the job expertise you have developed
over time
your skills should make the employers
feel that you have the required
abilities to succeed in the respective
job role
skills can often be the deciding factor
when it comes to proceeding with your
candidature
you can mention hard skills they are
basically technical skills that revolve
around your job profile
on the other hand soft skills may be
referred to as social or people skills
these skills like communication
adaptability problem solving and
leadership to name a few are soft skills
as shown alongside in this sample resume
for freshers
we have mentioned a few technical skills
while listing your skills it is wise to
use a two-column format that names the
skills and your level of experience with
the skill
here we have taken skills that are
primarily relevant in the data analytics
sector
you could change these skills depending
on the profile you are applying for
as you can see not only are you just
mentioning the skill but you are also
evaluating your expertise in it
if all the file boxes are colored it
shows you're proficient in it and vice
versa
this is a good way to showcase your
skills and it becomes
easier for the recruiters to identify
how good you are in the listed skills
our advice to you is to have the
relevant skills for the job you are
applying for
stay updated with the growing technology
and make sure your most recent skills
are reflected on your resume
here we have chosen skills like python
r machine learning data visualization
tableau and sql
the next section is another important
section on the freshers resume
as you are a fresher you might be
wondering how to convince the recruiters
of your skills and expertise
the best way to do so is by adding your
project details and internship
experience if any
since you have no work experience these
details can prove that you are fit to
start your career
in the previous section we saw how
important it is to list your skills
and in this section you should be able
to highlight hands-on cases of how you
have applied your skills
and capabilities to find a solution
you can first mention the name of the
project following which you could
mention the duration for the same
and then list out a few vital points as
to what you did
make sure to keep the content short and
crisp
depending on how you have carried out
the project your leadership qualities
can also be gauged by the hiring manager
remember to list relevant projects to
the job role you are applying for
as seen alongside under the project
section we have three projects
they are twitter sentiment analysis face
recognition
and uber data analysis you can notice
the duration given below each of these
projects
following which we have just a few
sentences on what our role was in the
project
these project details mentioned on this
sample resume can be of great value when
it comes to the field of data analytics
similarly it is advised that you add
relevant project details pertaining to
your field of interest
in addition to this you could also
consider adding a link to your online
portfolio if it has additional details
of your project
by doing so they will be able to see the
projects you have worked on
and how suitable your candidature is
here you can also add few details of
your internship if you have any
remember having internship details on
your resume is definitely a plus point
and it counts as a good experience
the next section on our resume is
extracurricular activities
it is imperative that you include
extracurricular activities on your
resume especially for freshers
as you lack work experience this is
where you realize how important
it is to be active in school and college
activities
so if you are one of those active
students then go ahead and showcase your
skills to prove your capabilities
under this section you can add any
activity that comes outside the scope of
your college or school curriculum
in this sample resume we have divided
the sections of extracurricular
activities
for better clarity and since this is a
freshers resume we have done so
the first thing you can have under this
section is any kind of participation in
webinars
workshops clubs etc as you see on the
screen
first here we have participation in
webinars and workshops related to data
science and machine learning
then we are listing the role of the
candidate as a part of the sponsorship
committee for tech events and cultural
fests
finally we are talking about a
non-technical activity that is the
formation of a plantation club to create
awareness
among people on environmental issues so
as you see we have three different kinds
of activities here
similarly you could go on and add any
kind of activity like part of the
student government
any college clubs volunteer work and
study abroad experience to name a few
now the next section we have is for
achievements
this section can be used by not just
experienced professionals but also by
freshers
here you could add any competitions you
have won in your student life
or any other sort of recognition you
have been awarded with
you can also add any scholarships if you
have received
it is great to mention these details on
your resume as it will make your
candidature look
good on the whole make sure to list only
those details that are true
as you can see here we have mentioned
securing fifth rank in a hackathon on
python programming
and then achieving a certificate of
recognition
for successfully organizing a startup
summit in college
so both these are achievements of the
candidate and for which she has been
duly recognized
there is absolutely no harm in
displaying your awards and recognitions
on your resume
next section on our resume is for your
certifications
so if you're looking to add your
certifications on your resume
this section can be well utilized
however if your certification is
job critical you could add them on top
of your resume as a part of your
headline as well
in other cases you can add it under this
section
so why is it important to have a
certification well because it proves
that you have specific expertise and
because it is issued by an authorized
organization
many jobs require you to hold certain
certifications
and sometimes more than one certificate
and if you are working in sectors like
accounting or finance
they definitely require licenses and
certifications
so the types of certificates vary across
sectors
a professional certification provides
evidence of your skills
and is proof that you have the required
work competence
certifications can certainly boost your
resume and help you stand apart from the
rest
your first duty is to put the relevant
certifications which align with the job
description
this will help the recruiter notice your
resume quickly
certifications are often used as a
resume filter by employers to narrow the
pool of applicants
for example an it security professional
could have relevant networking
certificates
to make his profile look more appealing
particularly if you are an entry-level
candidate or a student
listing relevant and in-demand
certificates will make your resume stand
out
at times recommended certificates can be
found in the job description as well
as shown alongside here we have the
candidate listing the completion of the
postgraduate program in data analytics
offered by simplylearn
the candidate is also a certified data
analyst professional from ibm
she holds a certification from google
for completing crash course on python
and she finally is also certified in
business analytics with excel course
that is offered by simply learn
reading these points will definitely
leave a lasting impression on the hiring
manager
and it will make you look more driven
and committed to your field of study
you need to regularly stay updated with
the ever evolving technology in order to
bag your dream job
on that note you all can check out the
simplylearn website to upscale yourself
and choose any certification from the
many options we have
having a certification will help you
develop skills for your career growth
simplylearn provides a cutting-edge
curriculum designed and guidance with
industry to develop job-ready skills
and the best part about these
certifications being that you can learn
by working on real world problems
here you will have projects involving
real-world data sets with virtual labs
for hands-on learning
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and upskill
yourself
next section on our list is about
languages
this section can be very impressive if
it is utilized well
so you might speak a second language but
you're unsure if it needs to be added on
your resume
well it definitely should go on your
resume the more languages the better
your candidature will look
knowing a second language also displays
cultural knowledge
you can flaunt your language skills to
your advantage here being proficient in
multiple languages can open a range of
opportunities in your professional life
listing your language skills can surely
make your resume more noticeable
communication is a critical part of any
job and recruiters often look for
language skills as they show
your capability to communicate with a
diverse range of people
the language skills on your resume could
include any other languages in which you
have intermediate advanced proficient on
native comprehension abilities
if a particular language can be
beneficial for the job role you're
applying for
then you need to have that language on
your resume as it may be a nice benefit
for the employer as well
if you know a foreign language it is
great as you can use your expertise to
communicate
well with international partners without
going through
an interpreter or a translator as you
can see alongside here we have two
languages
english and french it says english full
professional proficiency
and french limited working proficiency
it is good to have your level of
proficiency mentioned beside the
language as it will help the recruiter
understand how good you are in that
particular language
so before mentioning languages on your
resume you must review your speaking
reading and listening comprehension of
the language
and then add your proficiency level if
you know other regional languages
feel free to add those as well under
this section
language skills can surely help you grow
your professional network and provide
you ample job opportunities and help you
display your soft skills
the next section we have is for your
hobbies and interests
some of you might be unsure whether you
should include these on your resumes
well you definitely can it is best if
you add hobbies and interests that have
some form of relevance to the job you
are interested in
and let the hiring manager know you are
a good fit for the job
you could also do so by tailoring your
interests and by providing a variety of
hobbies
for example if you notice that the job
you're applying for wants outgoing
candidates
who are good team players then you need
to tailor your list of hobbies around
this
this way you can make use of this
section to your advantage
be sure to include your hobbies and
interests towards the end of your resume
keep this section short and do frame
your interests creatively
as seen we have a few interests here
like reading
traveling cooking and gardening on our
resume you could also add your hobbies
and interests accordingly
the next tip to you is to be honest
while crafting your resume
ensure you don't add any false
information as it will leave a
bad mark on your profile forever you
think honesty might not be the best
policy in this case
but it very well is still the best
policy even when it comes to building
your resume
recruiters can easily understand if
you're exaggerating and if your resume
looks to be
more of a fiction than fact for example
you cannot lie that you have passed out
from an ivy league university when the
reality is totally different
keep in mind that your educational
background will be checked by the
recruiters
similarly you cannot say you're
proficient in everything as
employers very well realize how much
people exaggerate their skill set
in such cases you'll be caught when
asked to demonstrate your skill set
also keep in mind that your job title
shouldn't look too good to be true
another most common mistake is trying to
cover a career gap in the wrong way
and you will be caught if the recruiter
does a thorough background check
if you are worried about a resume gap
fill it with any sort of consulting or
volunteering work
and not with false information
finally our last tip to you is to
proofread your resume
nothing can be worse than having typos
or grammatical errors on your resume
check for spelling mistakes and sentence
structure having such errors will leave
a bad impression on the recruiter
and you might seem careless in addition
to this
make sure your resume is well formatted
and you use the same font type
throughout your resume
sometimes employers can be quite picky
when it comes to hiring
hence the smallest typo on your cover
letter or resume might prevent you from
getting the job
proofreading ensures that your document
is free of errors and polished well
without proofreading our work has a
higher chance of containing errors
ask your family member or a friend to
proofread your resume as a favor
as having another person evaluating your
resume will be more beneficial
after incorporating all the about 10
tips that we have discussed
remember to share only the pdf version
of your resume with the recruiters
now let's have a look at the final
version of our sample resume that we
have been building
as you can see this is the first part of
our resume
as mentioned previously here we have the
name along with a photo
resume headline contact information
educational qualifications
and skills along with its ratings in our
next part we have the projects
extracurricular activities achievements
certifications languages and interests
make sure you align the resume well and
it looks neat and readable
stick to the same kind of formatting
throughout the resume
this is how the resume will look on the
whole
for freshers it is advised that you keep
your resume within two pages and not
more than that
a simple short and crisp resume will do
the job
if you want a copy of this detailed
resume that can help you grab your dream
job
please share your email in the comment
section below and we will send it over
to you
now that you have seen a handful resume
tips and you have learned how to write a
resume
let's go ahead and understand how to
write a cover letter
remember a sparkling resume paired with
a messy cover letter is definitely a red
flag
hence it is imperative that you know how
to write a good cover letter
you might have noticed that sometimes
some companies also require you to send
a cover letter along with your resume to
explain why you are a good fit for the
respective job
in those cases it is needed that you
know what exactly goes into a cover
letter
sometimes a cover letter may be optional
however it's usually a good idea to
include one in any application you
submit
a cover letter is a one page message
sent with your job application that
provides information about the job role
you are applying for
your qualifications your work experience
if any and you can also say
why you are interested in working for
that particular company
a very well written cover letter will
help you stand out
cover letters give you the opportunity
to demonstrate that you are a great fit
for the job you are applying for
a good cover letter can spark the
recruiter's interest in reading your
resume
on the other hand a bad one might just
mean that your application won't be
considered
so let's ensure that this doesn't happen
and learn how to write a cover letter
a cover letter's purpose is to introduce
you and briefly summarize your
educational and professional background
your cover letter typically should be
from 250 to 400 words
long it is important to remember that a
cover letter
is a supplement to your resume and
definitely not a replacement for it
having said that you cannot repeat
whatever is already mentioned on your
resume
all you have to do is keep the cover
letter format in mind
as you can see we first start the cover
letter with a header
with your contact information this will
include your full name on top
below that you will have your email
address your phone number
and your postal address in certain cases
you can also replace your address with
your professional work links and
personal website if you have one
after this you need to input the date
following this you need to mention the
name of the hiring manager
the professional title name of the
company you are applying to
company address and the company mail id
next you need to start writing the cover
letter content
and the first thing to do is to address
the cover letter to the hiring manager
you could find out who your hiring
manager is and address the letter to him
or her
if you are unable to find out you can
mention dear hiring manager
or to whomsoever it may concern now
moving to the body of your letter
you need to grab the reader's attention
with a few of your achievements
and explain why you're the perfect
candidate for that job
in this case since this cover letter is
for refresher you'll have limited
information
to fill in hence we have kept it short
and simple
and started by explaining where the
candidate found the job advertisement
and which post he or she is interested
in applying for
this makes it clear to the recruiter as
to for which post your profile should be
considered
in the next paragra we have mentioned
the name of the degree the candidate
holds
and you should also mention your
university name in addition to this you
can also mention any particular
achievement
or skills that you have which will be an
asset for the job you are applying for
in the case of experienced professionals
you can fill this section with a few
relevant
notable achievements from your work
history
after this we are going to have a
statement which speaks about your
attached resume for the recruiter's
consideration
you can also mention that you can be
contacted if you need to provide
more details you can then have a formal
closing statement
and thank the hiring manager for taking
time to consider your application
you can end it with a formal conclusion
and you are good to go
that was an example of a short and crisp
cover letter for refresher
before sending the cover letter make
sure to proofread it just like you would
for your resume
being an excellent candidate with
perfect set of skills won't help if you
cannot put them across through your
resume or cover letter
therefore it is a must that you craft
your resume well and follow our tips to
help you land your dream job
so that brings us to the end of this
session on resume building and cover
letter
i hope the session was informative and
interesting
good luck to all you job seekers out
there thank you for watching this video
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn